madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
membres du
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
députés mes chers collègues
horreur
sidération
angoisse le monde est aujourd'hui en
état de choc devant la violence de
l'attaque terroriste qui a frappé
Israël devant cette barbarie je dire ici
qu'Israël est un pays ami à qui je veux
réaffirmer au nom de la représentation
nationale notre totale solidarité et
notre soutien
inconditionnel
[Applaudissements]
al
l'URE à l'heure où nous parlons les
combats se poursuivent et le nombre des
victimes ne cesse de
s'alourdir nous pleurons également la
mort de quatre de nos compatriotes et
sommes toujours sans nouvelle de 13
d'entre eux rien ne justifie ni ne
justifiera jamais le
terrorisme aucune cause nautorise à
tirer sur des civils à enlever des
enfants à utiliser des otages comme
boucliers humain partout sous toutes ses
formes et sous tous ses prétextes le
terrorisme doit être condamné et
combattu sans ambigué et sans la moindre
nuance attenter à un pays démocratique
c'est attaquer toutes les démocraties du
attenter aux populations civiles c'est
menacer l'humanité
entière en hommage aux victimes en signe
de solidarité avec leurs familles comme
avec celles qui sont sans nouvelle de
personnes prises en otage ou porté
disparu je vous demande mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les députés de
bien vouloir observer une minute de
silence
je vous
remercie la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci M madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les
députés à mon tour madame la Présidente
je veux dire au nom du gouvernement mon
émotion et ma
solidarité face à l'horreur des attaques
terroristes qui touchent
Israël j'aurai l'occasion de m'exprimer
plus longuement dans un instant mais
d'ors et déjà et alors que le bilan ne
cesse de
s'alourdir je veux avoir une pensée pour
les victimes leur familles et leur
proche j'ai une pensée particulière pour
nos
ressortissants décédés lors de ces
attaques pour ceux dont nous attendons
encore des
nouvelles je veux enfin avoir un mot
pour la Communauté française en Israël
et pour les
franco-israéliens la situation est
éprouvante nous sommes mobilisés nous
sommes avec
eux mesdames et messieurs les députés je
veux le dire sans
ambiguité
la France se tient toujours au côté de
la
démocratie rien n'excuse le terrorisme
et la barbarie comme l'a affirmé le
président de la République desès samedi
nous sommes au côté du peuple israélien
dans cette épreuve je vous
remerci merci
beaucoup merci madame la Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre
je vous remercie donc l'ordre du jour
appelle les questions au Gouvernement je
vous rappelle que la Conférence des
Présidents a décidé que les 10 premières
questions seraient consacré à la
situation en Israël à raison d'une
question par groupe et qu'elle donnerait
lieu à une réponse globale de madame la
première ministre la première question
va être posée par Monsieur le Kester
sooti pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre je voudrais
m'associer toute à la fois à vos mots et
à ceux de madame la Présidente oui c'est
avec sidération et horreur que nous
avons reçu samedi matin ces images
terrifiantes horribles venant
d'Israël des massacres de civils étaient
perpétrés des vieillards ont été traqués
jusque dans leur
domicile des enfants ont été kidnappés
des femmes ont été violées
aujourd'hui les terroristes du Hamas qui
ont commis ces exactions
terrifiantes menacent d'assassiner les
otages dans d'autres temps dans d'autres
lieux nous avons connu les mêmes
scénarios à l'image de ce 13 novembre
2015 sur les terrasses parisiennes ou
des jeunes comme dans le désert du Négev
ont été pris pour cible à l'image du 14
juillet 2016 à Nice alors notre réaction
elle doit être celle de tous les
républicains de tous ceux qui sont
attachés à la liberté c'est-à-dire
condamnés sans réserve ceux qui ont
commis ces exactions ces terroristes
elle doit-être aussi de soutenir
totalement Israël en lui exprimant notre
fraternité en
humanité au-delà de ce soutien au-delà
cette
émotion madame la Première ministre des
réactions doivent intervenir nous ne
pouvons plus aujourd'hui je le dis et
c'est le sens de la résolution des
républicains accorder du financement
public
à ceux qui soutiennent ou financent le
terrorisme
imaginons pouvons-nous
imaginer pouvons-nous
imaginer la France financée
daesh et bien aujourd'hui nous le disons
il faut couper toute aide au
développement à ceux qui participent au
financement du terrorisme et il faut
[Applaudissements]
sanctionner
et il
fctionner lourdement totalement les
États comme l'Iran et le Qatar qui
financec le terrorisme madame la
Première ministre et êtes-vous prête je
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
remercie je vous
remercie madame la Présidente Panau pour
le groupe la France
insoumise madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre nos pensées se
tournent à cette heure vers le Proche
Orient où les peuples israéliens et
palestinien souffre encore une fois je
souhaite depuis cette assemblée exprimer
une pensée emplie d'humanité pour les
otages les civils tués en Israël par les
actes de terreur perpétrés par le Hamas
ainsi que pour les civils qui à Gaza
sont tués sous les bombes de tsal nous
condamnons tous ces crimes de
guerre un seul message doit parvenir du
concert des nations en cette heure si
grave une heure qui n'est en rien
propice aux polémiques
franco-française un seul message doit
parvenir du concert des nations cessz le
feu c'est un message qui nous vient du
Secrétaire général des Nations unies du
pape ou de Loula qui préside le Conseil
de sécurité des Nations unies cessz le
feu car le pire est à prévoir quand le
ministre de la Défense israélien assiège
Gaza privant 2 millions de civil d'eau
d'électricité et de nourriture violation
du droit international face auquel la
France ne peut rester
silencieuse nous n'avons jamais eu
autant besoin du courage de la paix que
dans ces moments cela fait trop
longtemps que la communauté
internationale a laissé la situation
sans
venimer de communiqués
du du président de la République pas un
appel au cesser le feu pas une fois le
mot paix notre pays rond avec la
tradition diplomatique qui est la notre
au Proche Orient depuis 65 ans il nous
faut uvrer au rétablissement d'un
processus de paix qui mène à deux état
sans quoi les horreurs passées
s'amplifieront non seulement des
atrocités présentes mais aussi des
désastres à venir aucune paix durable ne
peut voir le jour sans respect du droit
international et sans mettre fin à la
colonisation
alors allez-vous madame la Première
ministre retrouver la voix indépendante
qu'a toujours porté la France de Charles
de GA Chirac la voix de la France qui
quand elle parle est écouté la voix de
la France qui fait entendre la parole de
la paix et ne s'aligne pas sur les
positions V en guerre d'un gouvernement
d'extrême droite la voix de la France
quiéffirme que toutes les vie compte
sans exception la France madame la
premère ministre varver de la
paix la parole est à monsieur le
Président Maillard pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci
merci merci monsieur le Président
allez-y
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre il s'appelaient Tamar
et Jonathan ils étaient parents de trois
enfants et ont été tués dans leur foyer
ils s'appellent chiri Ariel Dita noir ce
sont des mères de famille des enfants
des personnes âgées des adolescents
enlevés et pris en otage actuellement
dans la bande de Gaza tous sont des
victimes du terrorisme du Hamas qui
depuis sème la mort et la désolation en
Israël déjà 900 civiles tués dont quatre
de nos compatriotes et plus de 2600
blessés des victimes assassinées mtilées
parce
qu'israélienne près de 150 otages qui
vivent en ce moment même
l'insoutenable attendent que leurs
joliers les
marchandent certains de nos
ressortissants pourraient même être
parmi eux alors que nous sommes toujours
sans nouvell de 13 d'entre eux
j'ai une pensée particulière pour etan
un enfant un français de 12 ans ce
climat de terreur certains voudraient
même le créer sur notre sol alors qu'une
vingtaine d'attaques antisémites ont été
relevées en 2 jours il est du devoir de
la représentation nationale de dénoncer
avec force ces actes de haine qui
sappent nos principes car toucher un
citoyen juif c'est touché à la
République dans ce combat commun de nos
démocraties contre la terreur
la complaisance aveugle l'ambiguité
coupable sont intolérables car rien
absolument rien et je dis vraiment
absolument rien ne justifie le
terrorisme
le président de la République l'a
réaffirmé avec plusieurs de nos alliés
Israël a le droit de se défendre madame
la Première ministre comment le
gouvernement compte-il assurer la
sécurité de nos concitoyens sur place
mais également sur notre propre
territoire je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Présidente Le Pen pour le rassemblement
national
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre chers collègues ce 7 octobre
2023 nous avons assisté à ce que nous
pensions ne plus jamais revoir dans
l'histoire de l'humanité des pogrom des
poogromes sur la terre même d'Israël au
cours desquels on a tué des femmes des
enfants des hommes uniquement parce
qu'ils étaient juifs ces attaques sont
un crime contre les humains mais aussi
un crime contre la paix contre cet
extraordinaire élan processus qui ces
derniers mois semblait progresser
rapprochant Israël et les nations
arabes nous Français nous avons revécu
avec effroi les horreurs du Bataclan ou
les turies d'enfant de Mohamed Mera les
scènes d'une violence inouie contre des
civils ou des militaires blessés ou tués
les prises d'otage y compris de
personnes âgées et d'enfants sont d'une
inhumanité rare
je veux dire ici que ceux qui
soutiennent
l'insoutenable l'excuse ou le relativise
et dont certains siège sur ses bans
attente aux valeurs
humaines il ils en répondront
politiquement y compris vis-à-vis de
leurs alliés et le cas échéant devant la
justice je réaffirme ici solennellement
notre soutien au peuple israélien frappé
au cœur aux familles touché dans leur
chair et à tous ceux qui souffrent dans
leur âme de ces abominations la lutte
contre l'IDRE islamiste que ce soit en
Israël ou en France est un enger majeur
pour notre époque notamment car elle
doit libérer certaines population dont
je crois une partie du peuple
palestinien prise en otage par des
mouvements islamistes terroristes cette
lutte demande des moyen mais elle
demande surtout une volonté politique
pour nous responsables politiqu français
l'urgence est aujourd'hui de protéger
physiquement mais aussi moralement les
Français juifs si sur le plan physique
le gouvernement a annoncé le déploiement
de forces de l'ordre sur le plan moral
comment comptez-vous faire respecter en
France l'interdiction de l'apologie du
terrorisme première étape dans la lutte
contre
l'islamisme je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier for pour le groupe
socialiste madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
le massacre de jeunes a une rve partie
l'exécution de bébés de vieillard
d'innocents le kidnapping d'otage y
compris d'enfants n'est pas un acte de
résistance c'est un crime
terroriste les actes du
doiv être condamné comme leur projet
politique qui n'est pas la paix et qui
exclut toute coexistence avec l'État
d'Israël notre condamnation est totale
le terrorisme n'est pas un moyen
d'expression aucune cause ne le justifie
aucun contexte ne l'excuse la fin ne
justifie jamais les
moyens
j'exprim nom des socialistes notre
solidarité avec les familles des
victimes et le peuple israélien
traumatisé chacun le sait désormais
l'embrasement est possible il y a un
scénario du pire qui s'écrit sous nos
yeux la tentation du chaos existe elle
est portée par tous ceux qui du Hamas à
l'extrême droite israélienne ont tout
fait pour tuer les accords
[Applaudissements]
d'Oslo pas être la vengeance aveugle
notre soutien à Israël comme à toute
démocratie frappée par le terrorisme est
indéfectible dans les limites du droit
international le droit humanitaire doit
être respecté le siège de Gaza n'est pas
acceptable la déshumanisation des
Palestiniens par le ministre israélien
de la Défense est une insulte à notre
commune humanité infliger une punition
collective à des populations civiles est
insupportable chaque vie
compte notre conviction est inchangé il
n'y aura pas de paix durable sans État
palestinien et sans garantie de sécurité
pour Israël nous appelons dans
l'immédiat le gouvernement français et
l'Union européenne à prendre une
initiative diplomatique pour inesser le
feu avant de convoquer ultérieurement un
sommet pour une issue politique la
guerre assez trop nombreux partisan la
paix a maintenant besoin de ses
combattants merci je vous
remercie la parole est à monsieur le
Président marcangéi pour le groupe
horizon merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre le 7 octobre
2023 restera dans l'histoire comme un
jour où le genre humain a montré sa face
la plus sombre le Hamas a mis en œuvre
une attaque organisée coordonné visant à
prendre le maximum de civil israéliens
en otage quand ils n'étaient pas
sommairement exécutés chez eux parfois
par famille
entière ce ne sont pas des crimes de
guerre une qualification qui s'applique
uniquement lorsqu'ils sont commis par
une armée régulière ici les méthodes
employées ont changé de nature et de
degré
elles sont en effet désormais
comparables à ce que l'État islamique a
pu faire de
pire le groupe horizon et apparenté
condamne fermement et unanimement ces
actes terroristes perpétrés par une
organisation terroriste il n'y a pas de
place pour aucune ambigué qui
bénéficierait à ceux qui commettent des
opérations barbares sur des femmes et
des enfants nous sommes solidaires du
peuple israélien et de toutes les
victimes je veux avoir une pensée
particulière pour les familles des
quatre Français dont la mort a été
confirmée à cette heure par le qu d'orsé
et celles qui sont encore dans une
longue et douloureuse attente la vérité
c'est que la cause palestinienne mérite
mieux qu'une organisation islamiste
terroriste qui n'hésite pas à prendre
des populations civiles qu'elle soit
israélienne ou palestinienne comme
boucliers
humains
et plus personne n'ignore que le but
ultime du Hamas n'est pas la paix mais
bien la destruction pure et simple de
l'État
d'Israël madame la Première ministre
pouvez-vous indiquer à la représentation
nationale quelle mesure la France compte
prendre pour assurer le rapatriment de
nos ressortissants lorsqu'ils le
demandent comment prévenir ensuite l' de
ce conflit dans notre pays plus
généralement enfin quelle est la
position de la France sur l'évolution de
la situation au Moyen Orient et en
Méditerranée je vous remercie merci
[Musique]
beaucoup la parole est à madame la
Présidente Chatelin pour le groupe
écologiste madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre chers collègues les
écologistes pensent aux familles aux
victimes à toutes celles et ceux qui
sont dans l'angoisse et dans la
l'attente de nouvelles de leurs proches
notre solidarité est totale les
Israéliens ont le droit absolu de
pouvoir vivre en
sécurité les écologistes condamnent sans
réserve les atrocités commises par les
terroristes du Hamas aucune lutte ne
justifie les tirs de roquettes contre un
hôpital aucune cause ne justifie la
prise d'otage et l'assassinat de civils
aucun acte de résistance ne justifie le
massacre de 260 festivaliers les
écologistes ne seront jamais au côté de
C de celles et ceux qui sèment la
terreur et la mort nous serons toujours
au côté de celles et ceux qui uvrent
pour la
paix face à la barbarie seul le droit
international est notre
réponse aujourd'hui les bombardements
incessants de Gaza et la mise en place
d'un siège total privant 2,3 million de
gazaou d'au de nourriture et
d'électricité nous alarmment au plus
haut point les propos déshumanisants du
ministre israélien de la Défense
comparant les Gazaouis à des animaux
laisse crainre un massacre dans la
prison à C l'ouvert que Gaza nous ne
pouvons plus tolérer cela la communauté
internationale a fait le Paris que le
conflit israëlo-palestinien s'étiendrait
de lui-même il a fait le choix de
regarder ailleurs les 72 dernières
heures nous rappellent à quel point
c'est une question géopolitique centrale
et la France a une responsabilité
majeure en tant que membre permanent du
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies le
gouvernement français ne peut se
contenter d'apporter un soutien aveugle
au gouvernement israélien la France doit
réaffirmer sa position historique pour
la coexistence de deux états vivant en
paix et en sécurité les Palestiniens ont
le droit absolu de vivre libre dans un
état souverain l'urgence est donc à un
cesser le feu au respect du droit
international et à la protection des
civils madame la Première ministre
comment votre gouvernement compte-il
agir en faveur de la délesescalade
comment la France compte-elle au sein
d'une démarche européenne agir
résolument pour la paix et la protection
des civils je vous
remercie la parole est à monsieur le
Président matthé pour le groupe
démocrate madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre quelle que soit la
cause que l'on défend elle restera
toujours desonor par le massacre aveugle
d'une foule innocente où le tueur c'est
d'avance qu'il atteindra la femme et
l'enfant disait Albert Camu depuis
samedi dernier les populations civiles
israéliennes sont victimes d'une attaque
terroriste massive et sans précédent de
la part du Hamas qui a causé l'effroid
dans la population israélienne plus de
700 personnes ont été assassinées dont
plus de
250 personnes qui participaient à un
moment de fête plus de 150 israéliens
hommes femmes et enfants sont retenus en
otage par les terroristes du Hamas dans
la bande de Gaza des quartiers des
villages ont été réduit en cendre et les
roquettes continuent de pleuvoir sur les
villes israéliennes mettant en danger
plus de 9 millions de civils cette
violence nous indigne et nous boueverse
profondément et ne peut laisser la place
à aucune ambiguité d'interprétation
quant aux motivations de ce groupe
terroriste face à ces crimes nous ne
pouvons rester silencieux ou pire
indulgent je veux le dire simplement
aucune lutte ne justifie le terrorisme
aucun conflit territorial n'explique ses
horreurs car au-delà des communautés
c'est bien la dignité et l'humanité qui
sont aujourd'hui
attaqué nous condamnons fermement ces
attentats les manifestations nombreuses
qui ont eu lieu hier en fin de journée
ont marqué la solidarité du peuple de
France vis-à-vis du peuple israélien si
durement touché nous étions nombreux à y
être et j'avoue avoir été
particulièrement touché par la
fraternité qui s'y'est exprimée je veux
dire au nom du groupe de mon groupe tout
notre soutien au peuple israélien nous
adressons nos condolances aux proches
des victimes de ces attentats et sommes
au côté des familles des otages madame
la Première ministre pouvezvous
pouvez-vous nous dire quelles seront les
actions à venir de la France et de
l'Europe surtout dans ce contexte de
crise aigu je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le
président
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Pancher pour le groupe lot madame la
Première ministre les députés du groupe
lot comme le monde entier ont découvert
eux aussi avec effroid les attaques du
mouvement terroriste hamass contre la
population civile israélienne c'est avec
la plus grande fermeté que nous les
condamnons sans aucune réserve queles
que soi les causes les humains ne
peuvent pas en arriver à de tels niveau
d'atrocité sur leur semblabl les
assassinats les prises d'otage d'enfants
en d'adultes de femmes ou de personnes
âgées sont des actes monstrueux nous
apportons notre totale solidarité aux
familles aux proches des victimes des
disparus des otages du Hamas prises dans
un chantage odieux il s'agit pour la
représentation française et pour les
responsables politiques que nous sommes
de faire preuve de responsabilité et de
dignité dans notre expression loin de
toute querelle politicienne les prises
de position avec de la en cher sans
aucune nuance cell cherchant des excuses
ou appelant à la vengeance ne peuvent
décemment être acceptables auou prises
avec un conflit d'une telle complexité
nul ici ne peut régler ses comptes avec
d'autres car ce serait une offense aux
victimes et à ceux qui continuent de
souffrir ceux qui sont dans l'angoisse
d'un enfant ou d'un parent disparu et
qui craignent pour leur vie je le dis
avec solennité il est essentiel que nous
donnions tous une autre image que celle
que nous voyons parfois dans cet
hémicycle
nous avons appris ce matin
malheureusement la mort de quatre
Français nous apportons évidemment notre
soutien et nos condoléances à leurs
familles à leurs proches nous demandons
au gouvernement les solutions qu'il va
mettre en place pour nos ressortissants
actuellement en Israël et qui souhaitent
revenir en France nous craignons un
déluge de feu à venir et en
élargissement du conflit il appartient
au-delà de l'émotion légitime immédiate
que la France l'Union européenne et
l'ONU puissent commencer à envisager des
solutions pour éviter un engrenage
incontrôlable madame la Première
ministre c'est dans ce sens qu'il nous
faut tous
uvrer je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie la parole est à monsieur le
Président chassigne pour le groupe
GDR madame la Première ministre le
groupe GDR et les députés communistes
ont condamné sans réserve l'attaque
terroriste perpétrée par le Hamas sur
les civils
israéliens nous avons nous avons nous
avons exprimer comme tous ici notre plus
profonde émotion face à la violence
aveugle qui s'est déchaîné sur des
femmes des enfants des vieillards une
condamnation qui s'impose mais elle ne
suffira pas à mettre fin aux violences à
protéger les populations à trouver le
chemin de la paix et de la sécurité
aujourd'hui Gaza est sous le feu des
bombes privé d'eau et
d'électricité le gouvernement israélien
israélien d'extrême droite promet de
traiter ses habitants comme des animaux
une vengeance terrifiante qui s'abat là
aussi sur des femmes des enfants des
vieillard des millions de civils
innocents la
France aussi madame la Première ministre
condamner cette opération vengeresse qui
va plonger plus encore les peuples les
Israéliens et Palestiniens dans le
désespoir et le deuil la France doit
lancer une initiative diplomatique forte
pour imposer le respect du droit et
mettre fin à 75 ans de duplicité de la
communauté internationale sur la
question
palestinienne une communauté
internationale qui par la VO de l'ONU
condamne la politique colonialiste
israélienne et le traitement réservé aux
Palestiniens privés de leurs droits
fondamentaux une communauté
internationale qui ferme les yeux sur
les résolutions bafouées par Israël la
France doit reprendre le flambeau de la
paix qu'elle a abandonné depuis tant
d'années être à l'initiative d'un
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU qui mette
fin à la politique d'occupation et se
consacre à la recherche d'une solution
de états
coexistant un état pour le peuple
israélien et un état pour le peuple
palestinien deux États dont les
frontières seraient protégé par la
communauté internationale alors alors
seulement seulement nous gagnerons une
paix durable pour mettre fin à la
spirale
destructrice je vous
remercie
chaque groupe politique sétant exprimé
je donne la parole à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames les présidentes Messieurs les
Présidents les présidents mesdames et
messieurs les
députés ce samedi 7
octobre l'horreur s'est abatue sur
plusieurs villes d'Israël et quelques
heures plus tard nous ons découvrir
l'ampleur la gravité et la barbarie de
l'attaque terroriste commise par le
Hamas des tirs de roquett massifs des
civils visés des femmes des hommes des
personnes âgées des enfants exhibés
humiliés pris en otage tués ces images
ont été un choc elles étaient
probablement encore en dessous de la
réalité dans les heures qui ont suivi
nous avons découvert 260 victimes dans
le désert des jeunes femmes et des
jeunes hommes sauvagement tués et encore
ce matin nous sommes frappés par
l'horreur avec la découverte d'un
charnier d'une centaine de corps dans le
kibuts de Berry à l'est de
Gaza ces drames ont un retentissement
particulier en
France notre pays connaît trop bien le
prix et les souffrances du
terrorisme notre pays a un rôle à tenir
pour défendre toujours la démocratie et
la
liberté à nouveau je veux dire mon
soutien aux victimes et aux familles
dont nous partageons la douleur
permettez-moi comme vous l'avez fait
messieurs mesdames et Messieurs les
présidentes et présidents d'avoir une
pensée particulière pour les familles
françaises qui souffrent
aujourd'hui
nous déplorons à l'heure actuelle quatre
décès parmi nos ressortissants et nous
cherchons encore des nouvelles de 13 de
nos compatriotes dont la situation est
extrêmement
préoccupante certains sont probablement
pris en otage parmi eux un enfant de 12
ans nous sommes en lien constant avec
les familles et mes pensées vont vers
elles et nous veillons en li avec Air
France à ce que des vols puissent
reprendre au plus
vite nous sommes face à une attaque
terroriste commise par un groupe
terroriste le Hamas un groupe reconnu
comme tel par la France comme par
l'Union
européenne avec l'aide du Djihad
islamique qui a aussi revendiqué ses
actes une attaque odieuse
inacceptable encore tout à l'heure le
président de la République s'est exprimé
dans les termes les plus clairs nous
condamnons ces actes avec la plus grande
fermeté l'ensemble des démocraties du
monde les ont condamné avec la plus
grande fermeté c'est la seule réponse
possible sans
ambigué
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
nous trompons pas sur ce qui vient de se
passer nous faisons face à un changement
d'échelle l'ampleur de l'opération sa
complexité son exécution tous ces
éléments le démontrent la barbarie et le
niveau de violence inimaginaable nous
rappelle les pires moments de notre
combat contre l'État islamique ceux qui
ont soutenu financé et armé le Hamas ont
basculé avec lui dans
l'ignominie dans ces heures graves la
responsabilité doit guider notre
action notre message est clair le
président de la République l'a rappelé
ce matin d'abord un soutien total à
Israël et à sa population nous à leur
côté et Israël a le droit de se défendre
face au
terrorisme face à la barbarie des
attaques terroristes personne ne peut
lui déigner ce droit
ensuite nous devons tout mettre en uvre
permettre la désescalade et éviter
l'embrasement de la région tous les
civils doivent être protégés et le droit
international
respecté la diplomatie est à l'œuvre le
président de la République a multiplié
les échanges avec ses homologues la
ministre des Affaires étrangères est
pleinement mobilisée avec l'ensemble de
nos diplomates nous restons en contact
très étroit avec nos partenaires dans la
région chacun doit mesurer les risques
de la
situation enfin je veux le dire nous
sommes vigilants dans notre pays et nous
ne tolérons aucun acte aucun propos
antisémite en
France
nous ne laisserons passer aucun
débordement ni sur la voie publique ni
dans l'espace numérique notre cadre
républicain est clair il s'appliquera
avec la plus grande fermeté à tous ceux
qui voudraient utiliser ce conflit comme
prétexte à l'antisémitisme que ce soit
dans nos rues dans nos écoles dans nos
universités et je veux adresser un
message à la communauté juive de notre
pays choqué et dont je mesure l'angoisse
nous sommes avec vous s'en prendre à
vous c'est s'en prendre à toute la
République dès samedi le ministre de
l'Intérieur a adressé des messages de
vigilance à tous les préfets et aux
forces de l'ordre avec le cours des
militaires de sentinell la protection
des lieux sensibles a été renforcée
enfin nos services de renseignement
travaillent activement à la détection
des menaces afin de prévenir tout acte
de violence mesdames et messieurs les
députés je veux également être clair sur
un point la France a toujours été
l'artisan de la paix elle le reste et
malgré l'horreur des événement ces
violences injustifiables ne doivent pas
nous nous détourner de la recherche
d'une paix dur au Moyen-Orient et d'une
solution politique dans le conflit
israélo-palestinien le le Hamas ne
cherche pas à répondre à ses aspirations
il a démontré que son seul objectif
c'est de faire couler le sang dans ce
contexte je n'ignore pas les
interrogations sur notre aide
humanitaire notre aide est versée à des
organismes de l'ONU sur place qui
agissent directement pour l'accès à
l'eau la sécurité alimentaire la santé
ou l'éducation nous sommes extrêmement
vigilants à ce qu'aucun euro d'ête
française ne parvienne à une quelconque
organisation terroriste ni à Gaza ni
ailleurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés
Israël un pays amis et allié vit un
traumatisme terrible un un traumatisme
qui nous replonge 50 ans en arrière
notre devoir est d'être au côté de la
démocratie notre devoir est de dénoncer
sans relâche le terrorisme notre devoir
est de tout mettre en œuvre pour trouver
le chemin de la paix grâce à la
diplomatie ce chemin sera très long mais
nous ne pouvons pas baisser les bras
nous devons tout faire pour trouver une
solution politique et mettre fin aux
décennies de ce conflit territorial
la France tiendra sa place dans ces
moments tragiques je trouve choquant et
désolant d'entendre des voix dissonnante
jusque jusque sur ces bancs c'est par la
cohésion nationale et par la défense de
nos valeurs républicaines que nous
pourrons être à la hauteur je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre
je vous
remercie nous allons reprendre le cours
plus normal de notre séance de question
gouvernement et je donne la parole à
Madame Ingrid dordin pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre des Sports et des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de France
madame la ministre notre pays
accueillera dans quelques moi l'un des
plus grands événements sportifs du monde
oui si les Jeux Olympiques bénéficient
déjà d'une très grande visibilité aux
yeux du public les Jeux paralympiques en
revanche restent malheureusement édition
après édition le parent pauvre de cet
événement les compétitions paralympiques
ne trouvent écho qu'auprès d'un public
restreint et la communication qui leur
est accordé est toujours dans l'ombre
des épreuves
dévalides pourtant nous ne pouvons
qu'encourager valoriser et être fi des
sportifs qui participent aux épreuves
paralympiques tant par l'importance des
efforts physiques qu'ils fournissent que
par la symbolique de persévérance et de
courage qu'il représente ainsi que de la
solidarité qui nous frappe à chaque
épreuve grâce à l'investissement
incroyable et pourtant trop trop peu mis
en valeur des
aidents ce dimanche 8 octobre vous avez
mis en œuvre à Paris une belle première
opération de promotion du sport pour les
personnes avec handicap et les
paraathlètes Tricolores le public y
était enthousiaste et révèle à quel
point l'intérêt peut-être fort auprès de
nos
concitoyens le sport démontre une fois
encore à quel point il est rassembleur
qu'on soit valide ou en situation de
handicap si l'inclusion est mise en
valeur sur le parcours de la flamme
olympique les associations
souhaiteraient également y voir leur
membres personne avec handicap et aidant
y participer à toutes les étapes c'est
d'ailleurs une demande forte chez moi à
Amien madame la ministre quelle est
l'ambition du gouvernement pour donner
enfin aux Jeux paralympiques la même
visibilité que les épreuves des sportifs
valides et que ces jeux soient le reflet
de notre dynamique pour une société
inclusive je vous remercie de votre
réponse merci beaucoup la parole est à
Madame Amélie oua casterra ministre des
Sports et des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée d'ordin en effet la 2e
édition de la Journée paralympique
dédiée au parasport a réuni ce dimanche
sur la place de la République 20000
personnes en présence du chef de l'État
c'est l'un de nos temps forts avec le
relais
paralympique
dans la route vers nos jeux nos jeux
paralympiques d'été qui seront les
premiers organisés par notre pays et le
plus grand événement
parasportif organisé de tout temps nous
voulons faire de ces jeux un rendez-vous
capital un levier d'abord pour changer
le regard que la société porte sur le
handicap en mettant en valeur les
performances exceptionnel de nos
champions en faisant vivre au grand
public et notamment à notre jeunesse aux
personnes en situation de handicap et à
leurs aidans ces moments de sport
extraordinairees les émotions que leurs
exploits suscitent et en faisant aussi
connaître les parcours hors normees les
leçons de vie qu'il y a derrière tout ça
nos jeux paralympiques seront inscrits
dans la durée dans la liste des
événements d'importance majeure ils
feront l'objet d'une retransmission
intégrale sur France Télévision et nous
pourrons ainsi admirer notre équipe de
France mais je veux reprendre les mots
d'Olivia Grégoire ici ces jeunes doivent
pas être seulement l'occasion de changer
le regard mais bien la vie des personnes
en situation de handicap c'est le sens
de notre feuille de route
gouvernementale et c'est le sens de nos
actions en faveur de l'héritage sportif
de cet événement pour diffuser une
pratique sportive plus accessib moins
cher plus diverse quel que soit le
handicap avec l'école avec le monde
médico-social avec les clubs sportifs
avec des aides comme le passeport la
billetterie au Jeux Paralympique est
ouverte 2,8 millions de billets dont 80
% à moins de 50 € il faut battre des
records ce de l'ondes des records
d'affluence alors tous au Jeux
Paralympique ils seront spectaculaires
et pour reprendre les mots de la
première ministre un accélérateur vers
une société plus inclusive je vous
remerci merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame edvich
Diaz pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre les Français assistent méduser
au lamentable spectacle d'un
gouvernement qui les prend pour des
imbéciles quand le ministre de
l'Intérieur montre les muscles en
affirmant qu'aucun migrant arrivé à
Lampedusa ne sera accueilli en France la
secrétaire d'État chargée de l'Europe
explique justifie et pire adère au fait
que l'Union européenne dans le cadre du
prochain pacte des migration impose une
amende de 20000 € par migrant au pays
refusant de se soumettre à son idéologie
immigrationniste 20000 € c'est 14 fois
le montant du SMIC autre exemple le
scandale de l'aide médicale d'État qui
nous a coûté l'année dernière plus d'un
milliard d'euros pour prendre en charge
les soins de plus de 400000 clandestins
là encore monsieur daranin joue au dur
alors qu'il a toujours refusé de
soutenir la proposition de Marine Le Pen
par ailleurs plébiscité par 2 tiers des
Français visant à supprimer l'ame pour
la remplacer par une aide médicale
d'urgence on apprend par la presse qu'il
change d'avis bienvenue au rassemblement
national monsieur Darmanin mais là
encore
là encore absence totale d'unanimité au
sein du gouvernement borne madame la
Première ministre alors que 2 millions
de ménages français sont en attente d'un
logement social que deux Français sur
trois ont déjà été contraints de
renoncer à se soigner qu'un Français sur
deux a déjà été obligé de se priver de
manger à sa faim est-ce que vous allez
continuer d'imposer votre coûteuse
politique immigrationniste et allez-vous
vous continuer encore longtemps de vous
soumettre au dictat de l'Union
européenne pour qui l'immigration
massive et anarchique n'est pas un
problème mais un
projet je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame Sabrina AGR roubage secrétaire
d'État chargé de la
ville madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
diz chacun peut observer que toute
l'Europe est soumise à une forte
pression migratoire en 2023 l'agence
Frontex enregistré pardon une hausse de
14 % des entrées irrégulières aux
frontières extérieur et un doublement
des arrivées en Italie mais en matière
d'immigration il y a ceux qui commentent
il y a ceux qui agissent la première
ministre a annoncé dès le mois de mai
l'expérimentation d'une border force à
la française à la frontière italienne
mobilisant conjointement police
gendarmes douaniers militaire de
sentinelle après les arrivées de
Lampedusa le ministre de l'Intérieur a
annoncé 200 s effectifs supplémentaires
à la frontière et puis en plus des 500
déjà mobilisés plus de 40000 reconduites
à la frontière ont déjà été effectué en
2023 le ministre de l'Intérieur vient
d'annoncer la la création de 11 cras 11
centres de
rétention pour atteindre une capacité
d'éloignement de 3000 places en centre
de rétention d'ici 2027 au niveau
européen sous l'impulsion constante du
président de la République je vous le
rappelle les États les états viennent
tous effectivement de trouver un accord
sur le pacte pour la migration et
l'asile réforme historique relancée sous
la présidence française à l'Union
européenne cette réforme permettra
notamment de créer des procédures
d'enregistrement et d'asile à la
frontière dès les débarquements en
Italie et donc de procéder au retour des
nationalités ne relevant pas de
l'asile les députés du le député du
rassemblement national bardéa
il n'a pas voté cette réforme vous
n'avez pas voté cette réforme non vous
l'avez pas voté au Parlement européen
alors que nous le savons bien seul une
réponse coordonnée au niveau européen
permettra de traiter un sujet de
dimension internationale au niveau
national au niveau européen chacun le
voit bien nous nous agissons sans
relâche merci madame la ministre je vous
remercie madame la
ministre madame la
ministre vous avez la parole merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
par votre mépris votre suffisance et
votre déconnexion ne venez pas vous
étonner que 60 % des Français ne
plébiscitent pas votre politique mais
nous nous avons un message pour les
Français nous leur disons que ce qu'ils
subissent n'est pas le résultat d'une
fatalité mais le résultat de vos
politiques et tout ça ils pourront la
changer ils pourront la changer le 9
juin prochain dans le cadre des
élections européennes enant pour
B la parole est à Monsieur Henry
Alfandari pour le groupe horizon merci
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
depuis samedi dernier un nouveau conflit
armé a débuté au Moyen-Orient une
organisation terroriste a lancé une
opération militaire d'ampleur contre
l'État d'Israël et des personnes
pacifiques sans défense qui ne souent
pas que la mort allait les séparer dès
l'UR nos pensées vont bien évidemment à
toutes ces victimes et à leurs familles
qui sont dans l'effroid et la peine à
cette heure notre rôle est d'être côté
d'Israël dans le combat qu'il livre
contre ces actes barbares et le et leur
commanditaires qui sont ne l'oublions
pas les premiers à utiliser leur
population comme bouclier humain pour
les couvrir de leur crime cet événement
est une surprise nous devons tous nous
interroger sur la capacité de nos
renseignements à prévenir de tels actes
nous avons vu dans cet hémicycle
l'importance de trouver des réponses
pour combattre le sentiment d'impunité
et le contrôle de la haine en ligne je
n'ose vous inviter mes chers collègues à
lire les torents d'immondice notamment
antisémites qui prospèrent en ce moment
et qui sont autant d'invitations au
crime partout sur le globe les terres
s'enbrasent les équilibres géopolitiques
du 20e siècle disparaissent au profit de
puissance régionale ou plutôt sur la
route d'affrontement entre Allian de
fortune qui peuvent nous entraîner tous
dans laabîe nos concitoyens constatent
en silence ils ont peur pour leurs
enfants les leurs et pour eux-mêmes ils
veulent connaître la place de leur pays
dans ce monde
ils veulent savoir quelle place nous
voulons donner à l'Union européenne dans
cette reconfiguration géostratégique ils
souhaitent aussi que les directive et
règlements de cette même Union
européenne permettent à leurs
institutions nationales de les protéger
vous l'avez bien compris derrière ces
conflit et cette réorganisation mondiale
c'est l'importation de ces dangers sur
notre propre sol qui nous inquiète
détermination et choix difficiles nous
attendent et nous devons pourtant être
également au rendez-vous de la dignité
humaine et de la démocratie monsieur
ministre comment comptez-vous faire
évoluer nos dispositifs et anticiper les
menaces pour protéger les Français sur
notre
sol je vous remercie monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Vigier
ministre délégué chargé des outr m
madame la présidente madame messieurs
les députés monsieur le député Henry
alfanderi toucher à un juif en France
c'est touché à la République comme l'a
dit le président billard ce sont les
mots de Géral d'manin l'autre jour je le
ré prends à mon compte et je l'excuse
parce qu'il est à avec le président de
la République en Allemagne cet
après-midi barbarie terrorisme horreur
les mots me manquent je crois revivre
2015 pour qualifier ce qui s'est passé
en Israël attentats qui ont été commis
par le Hamas que rien je dis bien rien
n'excusera jamais à la demande du
Président de la République et de la
première ministre le ministre de
l'Intérieur a immédiatement donné des
consignes très strictes à l'ensemble des
services de sécurité en particulier au
préfet pour protéger nos concitoyens
partout sur le sol nationale 582 lieux
communautaires juifs sont protégés comme
l'a dit la première ministre par 10000
policiers gendarmes militaires Sentinel
de façon à ce que on puisse éviter à
nouveau l'irréparable vous dire que
toutes les manifestations qui ont eu
lieu de soutien à Israël ont tout été
protégés et se sont passés dans les
meilleurs conditions vous dire aussi que
toutes les manifestations susceptibles
naturellement d'engager un trouve à
l'ordre public et faisant l'apologie du
terrorisme et bien simplement elles sont
interdites pour éviter une importation
vous avez bien compris du conflit sur le
sol français au travers de mes mots vous
dire que l'ensemble des services sont
mobilisés en lien avec la justice en
lien également avec le cyberespace la
plateforme Faros pour que partout je dis
bien partout on puisse protéger nos
constitoyens le thorisme doit pas passer
et nous devons tous je dis bien tous
être unis dans de telles circonstances
merci
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Arnaud lealp le
groupe la France
insoumise
ma ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finance la
semaine dernière des journaux français
étrangers ont révélé que la société
française NEXA a vendu un logiciel de
surveillance généralisé à plusieurs
dictatures et Milic pratiquant qui la
torture d'opposants qui des crimes de
guerre qui l'espionnage de journalistes
ou d'élus pour certains
français la mise en relation entre cette
société dont le numéro 3 a fait la
campagne d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 et un
client comme l'Arabie saoudite a été
facilité par Alexandre benala alors
membre du cabinet du Président de la
République d'après des documents cités
par les enquêteurs le Président en
personne aurait participé à au moins une
des réunions afférentes certaines
licences d'exportation par exemple aux
Milic du maréchal aftar en Libye ont été
accordés par le Ministère de l'économie
en dépit de l'embargo et des accusations
de crime de guerre visant ses milices
les faits révélés sont graves et les
questions nombreuses pourquoi ces
autorisations ont-elles été délivrées
pourquoi le président de la République
a-t-il cru bon d'aider cette société
quel rôle informel Alexandre benala
qu'utille de jouer au président auprès
du président de la
République pourquoi la justice
attend-elle toujours que soit déposée
une plainte du ministère de l'Économie
seule habilité à le faire pour violation
de l'embargo sur la vente d'armes et
pour complicité de
torture prétendre défendre les droits
humains quand on aide les régimes
égyptiens ou saouens entre autres à
réprimer leur population comment ne pas
craindre quand on découvre la
participation de l'exécutif à ces
opérations d'exportation de matériel de
surveillance de masse que certains
droits fondamentaux des Français so ne
soi pas menacés
[Applaudissements]
aussi je vous
remercie la parole est à monie jeanno
bar ministre chargé du
numérique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député d'abord permettez-moi
de saluer le travail d'enquête de la
presse pluraliste qui contribue comme
toujours à la manifestation de la vérité
vous dire ensuite monsieur le député que
les exportations de biens à double usage
tels que les systèmes de cyburveillance
que vous visez dans votre question sont
soumis dans notre pays depuis 2013 et la
loi de programmation militaire à des
procédures réglementaires et à des
autorisations administratives ces
procédures et ces administrations ont
pour but de garantir d'une part que ces
systèmes sont conformes à nos intérêts
et aux engagements internationaux de la
France et d'autre part à garantir qu'ils
ne puisse être détournés à des fins qui
sont contraires à nos principes et en
particulier au respect des droits de
l'homme et je peux vous assurer monsieur
le député qu'aucune autorisation n'a été
accordée qui soit contraire à ces deux
principes je peux également vous assurer
s'agissant du ministrere de l'économie
et des finances qu'à aucun moment
d'aucune forme que ce soit il n'a été
saisi de quelques demandes visant une
violation de l'embargo qui concerne la
libyie pour le reste une procédure
judiciaire est ouverte laissons la
justice faire son
travail je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur Leal merci pour votre
réponse qui rappelle les procédures en
vigueur toutefois l'enquête en cours
médiatique montre que ces procédures au
moins dans un cas s'agissant de
l'embargo n'ont pas été respectées donc
je renouvelle ma question le ministre le
ministère de l'Économie va-t-il porter
plainte pour le non respect de ces
procédures parce qu'il a été saisi par
le parquet national antiterroriste sur
la question et je la gravité des faits
fait que le groupe parlementaire la
France insoumise demande la création
d'une commission d'enquête sur les
prédateurs fa monsieur le
député la parole à Monsieur meer Habib
pour le groupe les
républicains madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre
50 ans jour pour
jour après le la guerre déclenché le
jour de quiip
pour nous venons de vivre le 11
septembre de l'État
juif cette fois c'était shabbat et le
gen sacré de
simrat la barbarie islamistes a frappé
des femmes des enfants des bébés des
vieillards des familles entières
décimées des femmes violées des corps
mutilées filmé exhibé devant une foule
galvanisée par la haine du Juif le ramas
c'est daesh
des juifs victimes de porome 120 années
après
kichiniev jamais depuis la tragédie de
la Choa autant de Juifs n'avent été
massacré le même jour mais cette fois
c'est en Israël quatre Français ont été
tué dans avidane ce magnifique jeune
homme n à Bordeaux quinzaine de disparu
et les 200000 Français d'Israël que j'ai
l'honneur de représentés sont menacés ou
sous les bombes je pense à eux ne vous y
trompez pas cette guerre est une guerre
contre notre civilisation entre la
civilisation et la barbarie non pas une
guerre de territoire les colonies mais
Israël a évacué Gaza jusqu'au dernier
centimètre carré le Hamas veut un état à
la place d'Israël mais pas à côté
d'Israël Israël est le premier rempart
contre l'islamisme qui a défiguré la
France avec 271 morts ces barbares
s'attaquent à notre modèle de société
nos valeurs notre art de vivre mais tout
notre conception du monde de la dignité
humaine si Israël perd cette guerre
c'est le monde libre qui va si c'est eux
ou nous n'oubliez jamais Sartre pas un
Français ne sera en sécurité tant qu'un
juif en France dans le monde pourra
craindre pour sa vie madame la Première
ministre la guerre sera longue est-ce
que vous pouvez m'assurer que la France
rendra directement le Hamas de la
sécurité de nos otages que la France
fera confiance à salale l'armée la plus
morale du monde pour détruire totalement
et écraser le Hamas qui qui a serv son
peuple que vous allez dissoudre la NPA
et autre qui font l'apologie du
terrorisme et enfin éviter les
manifestations comme à Sydney o on a
crié gazer les Juifs hier enfin depuis
que l'Assemblée nationale a voté les
pleins pouvoirs au Maréchal Pétin je ne
pensais pas que l'antisémitisme se
déchaînerait ouvertement à la gauche de
ces bancs l'histoire jugera cette 5e
colonne nichée au cœur de la République
je vous remercie je vous remercie
monsieur le député
monsieur Habib représentant les Français
qui vivent en Israël il m'a semblé
normal de lui lui laisser le temps de
s'exprimer complètement merci madame la
Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Meyer
Habib en tant que député des Français
établis en
Israël j'ai conscience de la gravité de
la situation à laquelle vous faites face
avec tous nos ressortissants sur place
je sais que vous êtes en lien permanent
avec eux et je veux vous remercier pour
votre
engagement une nouvelle fois je veux
dire à nos ressortissants qu'il peuvent
compter sur le plein soutien du
gouvernement je lu dis la première chose
qui nous vient à l'esprit c'est
l'horreur l'horreur du terrorisme
l'horreur des témoignages l'horreur face
à des hommes des femmes des enfants
massacrés des hommes des femmes et des
enfants enlevés dont des fillettes de 4
ans le Hamas groupe terroriste a agi
pour terroriser la population
israélienne face à ces drames
nous sommes au côté d'Israël et du
peuple israélien Israël a droit à la
sécurité droit de se défend rien ne peut
excuser le
terrorisme sur les otages le président
de la République a été très clair il a
dénoncé un chantage odieux et
insupportable du Hamas nous le
condamnons avec la plus grande
fermeté enfin Monsieur le Député vous
connaissez mon engagement et celui de
mon gouvernement dans la lut contre
l'antisémitisme aucune ambigué n'est
possible j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire aucun acte ou propos antisémite
n'est acceptable nous ne les tolérons ni
dans les cortèges ni sur les réseaux
sociaux et je veux rassurer tous les
Juifs de France nous les protégeons
c'est l'engagement du gouvernement c'est
le devoir de la République je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre la parole est à Madame
hugette tgna pour le groupe
conenaissance merci madame la
Présidente mdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la Santé
aujourd'hui c'est la journée mondiale de
la santé mental pour l'OMS il s'agit
d'un droit humain universel pour la
France c'est un enjeu majeur de santé
publique et pour cause près d'un adulte
sur 10 sur 6 serait touché cela
représente le premier poste de dépense
du régime général de la SC de la de
l'assurance maladie avant les cancers et
les maladies
cardiovasculaires la Cour des comptes
estime le coût total de ces troubl à 109
milliards d'euros par an si ce montant
n'est rien devant la souffrance intime
des patients et de leurs proches il doit
nous interpeller et nous pousser à agir
davantage c'est vrai en particulier pour
les enfants et les adolescents un jeune
sur C souffre de s trouble dépressifs
selon la selon santé publique France et
cette population est en forte
augmentation depuis la crise sanitaire
malgré les besoins identifiés il existe
d'importantes disparités territorial
aussi nous devons être au côté des
professionnels du secteur afin de leur
permettre de répondre aux besoins des
patients dans les meilleures
conditions l'an dernier le président de
la République a réaffirmé que la santé
mentale devait être au cœur de notre
stratégie de santé publique début 2023
les assises de la pédiatrie et de la
santé de l'enfant ont été engagé en
janvier j'ai déposé une proposition de
loi signée par plusieurs parlementair
qui vise à refonder le cadre de la santé
mentale des enfants et des adolescents
il nous faut poursuivre madame la
ministre nos efforts pour améliorer
l'attractivité des carrières augmenter
l'offfre de soins aussi madame la
ministre pouvez-vous nous préciser la
stratégie du gouvernement pour faire de
la santé mentale une grande cause du
quinquena notamment en faveur des
enfants et adolescents merci merci
beaucoup madame la députée la parole est
à Madame agès firmain le baudau ministre
chargée de l'organisation territorial et
des professions de santé merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée hugette tigna
merci madame la députée pour votre
question vous l'avez dit la santé
mentale des Français est l'un des
principaux enjeux de santé publique en
particulier suite à la crise du covid
c'est d'autant plus vrai en ce qui
concerne les plus jeunes et je vous
remercie d'avoir cette attention pour
eux en cette Journée mondiale de la
santé mentale en effet nous constatons
que les taux d'anxiété de dépression
chez les enfants et les adolescents se
maintiennent à des niveau important plus
élevé qu'avant la crise covid vous
l'avez signalé un jeune sur 5 souffre de
trouble de santé mental il s'agit d'une
préoccupation majeure et bien entendu
depuis 2017 le gouvernement s'est
pleinement saisi de cet enjeu et de
nombreuses action action ont été
développé le premier enjeu est de ne pas
laisser nos jeunes seuls et sans
information il est donc indispensable de
rappeler l'existance du fil santé jeune
service anonyme et gratuit qui propose
en ligne une écoute accessible 7 jours
sur 7 de 9h à 23h le 0800 235 236 il
s'agit ensuite bien sûr d'améliorer
l'accompagnement et la prise en charge
les assist de la santé mentale en 2021
ont permis de réaffirmer l'ambition du
gouvernement en santé mentale chez les
jeunes cela se traduit par le dével des
maisons des adolescents la formation à
ce jour a de près de 70000 secouristes
en santé mentale ou encore le
déploiement du dispositif momsi qui
donne la possibilité d'avoir jusqu'à 8
séances remboursées par l'Assurance
Maladie enfin nous avons souhaité
renforcer de près de 400 ETP les
ressources des CMP infantau juvéniles la
nécessité d'aller plus loin le récent
plan interministériel de lutte contre le
harcelllement à l'école porte ainsi de
nouvelles mesures en faveur d'une
meilleure coopération territoriale et
d'une meilleure formation sur la
problématique les conclusions des
Assises de la pédiatrie et de la santé
de l'enfant et l'installation prochaine
du CNR en santé mentale nous permettront
de construire de nouvelles solution
enfin je signale que santé publique
France lance une campagne pour inciter
les jeunes à prendre soin de leur santé
mentale notamment au cours de cour
courte vidéo vous le voyez madame la
députée le gouvernement agit de façon
résolue sur ce sujet
essentiel merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Joël
aviranier pour le groupe socialisteci
présidente une nouvelle
questionsur madame la ministre nouvelle
question sur la santé mentale mais cette
fois-ci avec des propositions
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 10 octobre et
c'est la journée mondiale de la santé de
la santé mentale la pandémie de covid-19
et ses multiples confinement ont
accéléré la détérioration de la santé
mentale de nos concitoyens or notre pays
n'est actuellement pas préparé pour
affronter ce défi majeur conscient de
cette situation avec ma collègue Chantal
jourd et moi-même nous avons été chargé
par le groupe socialiste de travailler
sur ce qui apparaît aujourd'hui comme un
angle mort de nos politiques de santé
après 6 mois d'audition hebdomadaire de
tous les acteurs du domaine et des
visites de terrain les députés
socialistes présentent 10 mesures pour
faire de la santé mentale une grande
cause nationale la santé mentale est le
premier poste de dépense l'assurance
maladie avec 23 milliards d'euros
cependant nous sommes loin des coûts
directs et indirects des troubles pour
la société qui en 2010 18 représentait
163 milliards d'euros il est urgent
d'agir nous devons changer d'approche et
aller vers un objectif zéro contention
zéro isolement en psychiatrie comme le
préconise l'OMS nous devons faire
évoluer les pratiques en psychiatrie
vers le rétablissement des patients en
réorientant progressivement les moyens
de l'Hospitalier vers l'ambulatoire à
moyen constant nous devons former
davantage professionnels mais aussi
mieux les former en bref nous devons
remettre l'humain au cœur de la gestion
de la santé mentale qui s'agisse des
professionnels comme des citoyens la
santé mentale est tout aussi importante
que la santé physique mais actuellement
nous constatons que la psychiatrie et la
pédopsychiatrie sont les parents paures
de notre système de santé déjà affaiblis
par des décinis de vision gestionnaire
et comptable notre pays doit répondre à
ce défi majeur et c'est pour cela que
nous espérons que cette initiative
trouvera un écho dans cet hémicycle
madame la ministre êtes-vous disposé à
travailler avec nous et avec toutes les
bonnes volontés de la S nationale sur ce
sujet essentiel je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le député la parole
est à Madame agè fmain lebudeau ministre
chargé de l'organisation territoriale et
des professions de santé merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Joël
aviragier je viens de le dire à notre à
votre collègue g tien la promotion de la
santé mentale fait partie des priorités
de la politique menée par le
gouvernement je vous remercie donc de
cette question en cette Journée
internationale de la santé mentale ce
qui explique le petit ruban vert nous le
savons à présent la crise du covid a
notamment eu un impact très important en
matière de santé mentale de nos
concitoyens dès juin 2018 en cohérence
avec les objectifs de la stratégie
nationale de santé le gouvernement a
adopté une feuille de route santé
mentale et psychiatrie reposant autour
de trois piliers la prévention le
parcours de soins et l'insertion sociale
cette feuille de route a été enrichie en
2021 par les 30 mesures issues de la
conclusion des Assises de la santé
mentale et de la psychiatrie de
nombreuses actions concrètes ont donc
été conduites avec la la construction
d'une stratégie nationale et de
prévention du suicide la création du
dispositif momsi le renforcement de
maisons des adolescents l'amplification
du déploiement du secourisme en santé
mentale dans tous les milieux avec plus
de 70000 personnes formées ou encore la
stratégie de déploiement des compétences
psych-ocial avec la création de la
génération 2037 l'ensemble de ces
actions s'appuie sur des moyens inédits
avec un budget total de près de 2
milliards d'euros entre 2022 et 2026 ce
qui constitue une délégation de de
crédit pérenne à un niveau historique
comme vous le voyez même si vousettez
parfois de le rappeler de nombreuses
actions ont été entreprises beaucoup
restent à faire et vous le savez le
sujet de la santé mentale est bien plus
global qu'un sujet de santé en
particulier sur le volet des ressources
humaines il nous faut renforcer nos
connaissances ainsi que les ressources
disponibles dans le périmètre de la
santé mentale de la psychiatrie il nous
faut en particulier renforcer les
coopérations et le partage des
compétences c'est pourquoi nous
souhaitons par exemple accélérer le
déploiement des infirmiers en pratique
avancé ou encore des psychologues an par
le Président de la République le
lancement prochain d'un CNR en santé
mentale doit nous permettre d'aller plus
loin en faveur de plus de prévention
d'innovation dans la prise en charge
globale de la santé mandale et nul doute
que vos propositions y
trouveront je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame Sandra
regol pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues ce 10 octobre c'est
aussi la journée internationale de lutte
contre contre le sansabrisme et en la
matière les chiffres sont sans appel 130
% d'augmentation du nombre de personnes
à la rue sur les 10 dernières années
2000 enfants sans logement cette année
soit 20 % de plus que l'année précédente
pourtant je dois le concéder vous n'avez
pas rien fait ces 10 dernières années
l'État a augmenté l'enveloppe consacrée
à l'hébergement de votre côté vous avez
lancé l'Observatoire du sansabrisme et
aussi les deux plans de logement d'abord
mais je dois reconnaître que sur le
barrain c'est 70 personnes pris en
charge sur le millier de personnes qui
appellent le 115 vous reconnaîtrez qu'on
y est pas tout à fait bref
l'investissement n'a jamais été aussi
élevé et malgré tout les appels au 115
sont de plus en plus nombreux preuve que
le problème n'est pas seulement
financier il est systémique inflation
crise creusement et renforcement des
inégalités de fait les moyens déployés
aujourd'hui correspondent aux enjeux
d'hier et toutes les grandes villes de
France ont le même constat ell P les
manques gérant dans l'urgence la grande
précarité qui est pourtant une
compétence de l'État et ce sans
accompagnement
adapté association et collectivité ne
sont ni associés ni informés des
décisions et en un mot elles sont
aujourd'hui à bout conséquence à
Strasbourg en premier lieu mais aussi
Lyon Rennes Bordeaux Paris Grenoble et
d'autres ces villes vous attaquent en
justice pour dénoncer le
sous-dimensionnement de votre action
mais derrière cette demande il y a une
demande simple vous demandez de sortir
d'un système fondé sur la méfiance d'un
système fondé sur la suspicion à l'égard
des collectivités et des associations ce
que ces villes vous demandent ce que
nous vous demandons c'est un choc de
confiance mesdames et messieurs les
ministres accepterez-vous enfin de
coconstruire dans le pluralisme les
solutions d'aujourd'hui et surtout
celles de demain je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier verrand
ministre chargé du renouveau
démocratique et porte-parole du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée regol d'abord merci pour la
pondération de de votre question et
d'avoir reconnu qu'effectivement s'il
reste des problèmes criants notamment
dans certaines grandes métropole que
vous avez cité en matière d'hébergement
d'urgence un effort sans précédent a été
réalisé par l'État c'est-à-dire via les
impôts des Français je me souviens ayant
occupé le poste de la ministre que j'ai
l'honneur de remplacer le temps de cette
question au gouvernement parce qu'elle
est en Allemagne avec le président de la
République madame Aurore berger à
l'époque pendant le covid nous avions
atteint les 200000 logements hébergement
d'urgence un nombre totalement dessus de
ce que tout ce que nous avions connu
dans notre pays et pour autant vous
l'avez souligné malgré le choix de la
première ministre de maintenir un très
haut niveau de parc et d'hébergement
d'urgence et bien les comptes ne sont
pas bons encore trop de personnes trop
de familles sont à la rue vous l'avez
dit la solution elle doit être
structurelle et là aussi je vous rejoins
et d'ailleurs c'est la volonté que nous
avons avec le plan quinquenal que nous
avions présenté en 2018 ce sont 440000
personnes quand même qui ont pu sortir
de la rue et accéder à un logement
pérenne et les solutions structurelles
maintenant quelles sont-elles d'abord la
création de 300 places ce qu'on appelle
l'intermédiation locative pour permettre
à des personnes qui sont en grande
précarité de bénéficier d'un logement
dans le parc privé à un tarif abordable
ensuite mieux accompagner les plus
démunis au quotidien notamment
l'ouverture de nouveaux sites dans le
cadre du dispositif un chez soi d'abord
avec après une expérimentation qui a été
concluante c'est une mesure qui prévoit
un accès direct au logement depuis la
rue ainsi qu'une prise en charge au
domicile par divers professionnels vous
savez très bien que c'est pas qu'un
sujet de logement il faut souvent aussi
un accès à l'emploi et à la santé et
enfin améliorer le fonctionnement de
l'hébergement d'urgence avec le
recrutement quand même de 500 personnes
supplémentaires pour venir renforcer le
dispositif du 115 la main que vous
tendez en direction de l'État pour
qu'elle travaille avec les collectivités
nous la saisissons madame la députée
parce que c'est fondamental de
travailler en la matière avec les
collectivités avec les associations et
pour conclure vous me permettrez de
m'associer à vos remerciements de notre
modèle associatif qui est solide et qui
nous permet de tenir dans des conditions
difficiles merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre madame
regol
merci Monsieur le Ministre j'en retiens
donc que votre réponse du gouvernement
sera favorable à la demande de pour
l'instant civille de France et bientôt
d'autres c'est donc noté merci beaucoup
madame la députée la parole est à Madame
Mathilde Paris pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre du Travail et de l'insertion la
réforme des retraites don vous aviez
hâte de tourner la page se réinvite dans
le débat avec la scandaleuse tentative
de Hold Up du pécule de la jirque Arco
vous avez essayé de faire avaler au
français la retraite à 67 ans en leur
promettant une retraite minimale à 1200
€ qui s'est révélé être un mensonge et
honté tant sur le montant qui était du
brut et non du net que sur le nombre de
bénéficiaires passés de 2 millions à
seulement 20000 voire 10000 suite à vos
aveux maintenant nous découvrons que
vous ne saviez pas comment financer
cette promesse et qu'il vous faut
trouver un à 3 milliards idée de génie
penseiez-vous nous allons piocher dans
la caisse de l'agir Carco qui grâce à sa
bonne gestion a accumulé 6 mois de
réserve si elle refuse nous passerons en
force grâce au opfss le parti
présidentiel en marche devenu
Renaissance devrait être rebaptisé par
la force tant le passage en force est
devenu votre modus opérandi passage en
force avec l'usage immodéré du 493 pour
contourner le vote de l'Assemblée
nationale et contrer la volonté du
peuple français et maintenant pour
obliger une caisse de retraite
complémentaire privée à donner un à 3
milliards à l'état monsieur le ministre
on ne joue pas avec la vie des Français
car précisément ce sont 58 millions
d'assurés de laagir Arco qui vont être
volés en cette période d'inflation
terrible pour le pouvoir d'achat des
Français la caisse de retraite
complémentaire comptait revaloriser les
pensions de ses assurés grâce à ses
excédents non seulement elle ne sera
plus en capacité de le faire si vous
persévérez dans ce pillage organisé mais
vous allez gravement fragiliser l'AG
Carco et sa capacité à faire face aux
crises nous députés du rassemblement
national disons stop stop au saccage de
notre système social stop au pillage de
l'argent des Français stop à ce
gouvernement et à ces politiques
délétaires monsieur le ministre quand
allez-vous arrêter de faire payer vos
erreur à la France qui travaille quand
allez-vous cesser de ronger le pouvoir
d'achat de millions de retraités et de
salariés laissez les Français qui
travaillent vivre dignement de leur
retraite arrêtez de saccager notre
système social merci la parole est à
Monsieur Monsieur Olivier dusopte
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Paris monsieur madame la
députée vous n'avez pas voté la réforme
des retraites et vous n'avez appris vous
n'avez assumé aucune responsabilité au
moment de ce débat qui avait un objectif
qui était le retour à l'équilibre
qu'avons-nous dit aux partenaires
sociaux au mois de novembre dernier à
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux qui
ont participé aux concertations nous
leur avons dit que la réforme que nous
présentions est une réforme qui permet
un retour du régime de retraite à
l'équilibre tout régime confondu nous
avons toujours dit en transparence que
les économies réalisées les excédents
réalisés grâce à la réforme dans
l'ensemble des 42 régimes devaient
participer au retour à l'équilibre
général lorsque vous parlez de laagir
Carco c'est un système qui est bien géré
je vous le concède et je le partage avec
les partenaires sociaux il est bien géré
parce que les partenaires sociaux il a 4
ans ont décidé eux-mêmes de la mise en
place d'une décote temporaire sur les
retraités qui partaient avant 65
nous leur avons dit à l'ouverture des
négociations que nous considérons qui
àhorizon 2026 sur le total des excédents
de laagir Carco 1,2 milliards sont des
excédents qui n'existeraient pas sans la
réforme des retraites que nous avons mis
en place et nous leur avons dit en
transparence que nous considérons que
cet argent devait servir et devit être
mobilisé pour le retour à l'équilibre du
régime général les partenaires sociaux
jusqu'à demain pour signer un accord cet
accord ne prévoit que des dépenses
nouvelles des dépenses d'indexation la
suppression de la décotte pour les
nouveaux traité comme pour les actuels
il prévoit des dépenses nouvelles
financées pour l'essentiel par le
rendement de la réforme des retraites
nous avons fait confiance au dialogue
social et aujourd'hui nous regrettons
que les partenaires sociaux n'ai pas
pris en compte cette nécessaire
responsabilité pour nos finances
publiques nous continuons à discuter
nous continuons à échanger cet accord en
terme de dépenses publiques parce que
les dépenses de laagir Carco sont des
dépenses publiques et comptabilisé ainsi
aux yeux de l'Union européenne cet
accord déséquilibre les comptes publics
pour 1 milliard d'euros ce à quoi nous
allons devoir répondre il s'agit pas
d'aller chercher un pcule il sagit pas
deer chercher dans les réserves et
Madame la député je vous le dis une
série de mauvais jeux de mots et une
série de TR ne fait pas la
responsabilité merci Monsieur le
Ministre la
parole la parole est à Monsieur Thomas
madame
Laurence pour le groupe
démocrate j'anticipe tu veux poser la
question
allez-y merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre délégué au comptte
public lutte contre l'inflation
réduction du déficit investissement vous
avez défini les trois objectifs du
projet de loi de finance pour 2024 c'est
une politique que nous approuvons
pleinement mais bien sûr tout est dans
la pondération entre ces trois objectifs
car la lutte contre l'inflation
conduitite en fait à des dépenses
supplémentaires vous les avez chiffré à
37 milliards pour l' anné 2023 la
réduction du déficit consiste
nécessairement en une réduction des
dépenses publiques si l'on ne veut pas
augmenter les prélèvements obligatoires
et l'investissement ce sont d'abord de
nouvelles dépenses quel que soit le
bénéfice que l'on en attend le plus
sensible de ces trois objectifs est
évidemment la réduction des dépenses
publiques on pense d'abord à
l'importance des transferts sociaux dont
beaucoup considèrent qu'ils sont trop
élevés en France une réponse forte a été
apportée avec la réforme des retraites
que votre gouvernement a mené avec
courage et détermination nation outre la
lutte contre les fraudes fiscales et
sociales et la réforme de l'assurance
chômage et de l'assurance maladie qui
doivent contribu à la réduction des
dépenses publiques le projet de loi de
finance table sur une meilleure
performance des dépenses des
collectivités locales sur ce dernier
point monsieur le ministre je souhaite
vous poser deux questions peut-on
envisager une réforme structurelle de
notre millefeuille administratif qui n'a
pas été sérieusement remis en cause par
la dernière loi de
décentralisation peut-on envisager une
plus grande maîtrise de leur recettees
par les collectivité locale ce qui
pourrait peut-être apporter une
limitation de leurs dépenses je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
députée donc la parole est à Monsieur
Thomas kazenav ministre chargé des
comptes publics merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les les
députés madame la députée face aux
crises multiples que nous avons
rencontré l'État à protéger l'État à
protéger massivement les Français les
salariés les entreprises les
associations les collectivité
territoriale et il nous faut redresser
nos finances publiques avec 5 % de
déficit avec 3000 milliards de dette
c'est le sens du du projet de loi de
finance que nous allons défendre et que
nous défendons en commission mais pour
redresser les finances publiques il nous
faut partager les efforts c'est l'état
c'est la sécurité sociale et c'est aussi
les collectivités territoriales nous
avons toujours dit que nous comptions
sur elle pour participer à l'effort de
redressement des finances publiques nous
leur demandons pas d'ailleurs de baisser
la dépense mais que la dépense évolue
moins vite moins vite que l'inflation
moins vite que l'inflation et c'est dans
ce cadre là que nous les invitons
d'ailleurs à imaginer nouvell méthode
avec nous il y aura pas de contrat de
chaor il n'y aura pas de il n'y aura pas
il n'y aura pas de contrat de chaor
puisque si vous me laissez terminer la
réponse à madame vevski monsieur le
député vous en déplaise la réponse que
que j'apporte il n'y aura pas de contrat
de cahor c'est un contrat de confiance
avec les collectivités territoriales de
nombreux élus sont persuadés que oui
nous devons redresser nos finances
publiques et comment nous nous mettons
d'accord sur des missions en commun pour
ralentir la dépense et oui nous évoquons
par exemple la question de notre
organisation administrative l'État
opérateurs Agen quatre niveaux de
collectivité est-ce que cette
organisation on peut continuer à cela
payer et c'est un objet c'est un objet
de discussion avec les collectivités
dans le casre du Haut conseil aux
finances publiques locales que nous
avons tenu avec Bruno Le Maire et
Dominique fort maîtriser la dépense pour
investir dans l'avenir avec une méthode
le dialogue et la confiance avec les
collectivités territoriales merci
beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Karen
Hodi pour la France insoumise merci
Madame la merci merci merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
on sait Thomas braille déjà très
affaibli en grève de la fin depuis 40
jours avec 14 autres gréistes contre la
69 il a fait un malaise aujourd'hui au
petit matin et a été transféré à
l'hôpital alors que ses opposants à ce
projet écidèent jettent leur dernière
force dans la bataille contre ces
travaux vous vous ob obstiné et vous
foncez contre la la construction d' A
décidé au siècle dernier un projet d'un
autre temps pour des élus du en même
temps quand allez-vous arrêter ces
travaux 3 jour de suspension d'abattage
vous plaisentez madame le Premier
ministre reprendre les abattages samedi
prochain c'est un changement de braquet
que nous demandons si vous n'entendez
pas vos opposants dans l'hémicycle
entendez au moins la grandonde
écologique qui monte de toutes part vous
l'entendrez mieux lors de prochaines
mobilisation prévu le 21 22 octobre
prochain dans le temps les mobilisations
s'amplifient nous étions 3 samedi à lî
surtand pour dire non aux quatre usines
d'enrobé qui alimenteront le projet de
la 69 la semaine dernière nous ét 750
personnalité à signé une tribune d'
libération appelant à un arrêt des
travaux le lendemain ce sont près de
1500 scientifiques dont plusieurs
auteurs du GC nous ont emboité le pas
rien ne vous fait reculer pour ce projet
opaque qui est l'emblème d'une fuite en
avant j'ai consulté le dossier de
demande d'autorisation environnementale
on y trouve quoi des pages grisées motif
secret des affaires à l'heure où
l'éternaet prépare les festivités de
Noël sous 30 degrés à l'ombre vous
imposez toujours plus de véhicules sur
sur la route des grands projets en
contradiction totale avec les annonces
de transition écologique prolifère comm
prolifère les punaises de lit on
connaissait le président des ultr riches
VO voici maintenant le gouvernement des
fermesusines des méga bassines et des
routes
inutiles un projet alternatif un projet
alternatif existe innovant proposé par
le collectif la voie
si ce projet ne vous convient pas alors
faites
mieux je vous remercie madame la députée
la parole est à monsieur Clément bonne
ministre en charge des
[Applaudissements]
transports merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée hodie il y a beaucoup de
confusion d'amalgame et beaucoup de
contrevérité dans votre question alors
je vais essayer de répondre parce que
nous sommes tous des responsables
politiqu avec des principes simples qui
devraient tous nous guider
d'abord et nous y sommes évidemment
attachés plus que tout la protection de
la vie et c'est pour ça que j'ai suivi
heure par heure même avec plusieurs
échanges les sujets les questions de
santé pour Monsieur braille et pour
d'autres personnes qui mettent leur vie
en danger et nous n'hésiterons pas à
prendre toutes les mesures de protection
et d'intervention humanitaire nécessaire
à chaque fois que cela est nécessaire
car l'honneur de notre modèle social
c'est aussi de protéger les gens contre
eux même lorsque les interventions sont
indispensable nous le ferons il n'y a
pas un monopole du cœur nous sommes
évidemment extrêmement attentifs à cette
question avant tout ensuite évidemment
la question de la démocratie et de
l'État de droit qui devrait tous nous
réunir et je suis surpris que vous
fassiez fille des 500 réunions publiques
des milliers de débats qui ont eu lieu
des décisions politiques démocratiques
répété qui sont porté par des élus qui
ont la légitimité démocratique évidente
des procédures de justice nous sommes je
le redis dans un état de droit qui ont
eu lieu qui sont ouvertes à tous il y a
eu encore une procédure en référé
vendredi dernier la 5e qui ont toutes
été respecté le juge vendredi a décidé
même immédiatement qu'il n'y avait aucun
motif pour donner une nouvelle décision
qui aurait amené à une suspension c'est
cela qu'il faut entendre aussi et puis
bien sûr le principe qui devrait là
aussi nous rassembler c'est la question
de la responsabilité la question de la
responsabilité c'est de ne pas pousser à
l'excès c'est ne pas pousser à la
radicalité c'est de ne pas pousser au
martyr et chacun une part de
responsabilité à cet égard madame la
députée j'ai la mienne vous avez la
vôtre et assumezla et puis la
responsabilité c'est toujours avoir un
dialogue serein c'est notre ligne celle
de la première ministre celle du
gouvernement et la mienne sur tous les
projets et c'est la raison pour laquelle
de nouveau en préfecture à ma demande il
y aura une réunion en fin de semaine
avec l'ensemble des élus concernés et
les association seront reçu une nouvelle
fois aussi comme je l'ai fait moi-même
avec mon équipe avec Carole delg à de
nombreuses reprises ces principes
devraient nous guider ils sont
essentiels sinon il n'y a plus de
fonctionnement démocratique c'est
important de le souvenir de s'en
souvenir et de le partager madame la
députée merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre ma cher collègue c'est donc un
moratoire assumé et faites vivre la
démocratie je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Stéphane pe pour le
groupe GDR merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre du
Logement vous avez pris la semaine
dernière devant le Congrès HLM réuni à
Nantes un engagement confortant le prêt
à tau zéro pour soutenir l'accession
sociale à la propriété et a annoncé une
enveloppe de 1,2 milliards d'euros sur 3
ans pour la rénovation énergétique nous
saluons ces propositions mais nous
exprimons notre notre profonde
inquiétude sur l'absence de mesures de
soutien à la production de logements
sociaux pourtant la situation du pays le
commande le chiffre de 2,4 millions de
ménages en attente de logement HLM doit
être pris pour ce qu'il est le signe
clinique qu'une part croissante de la
population ne parvient pas à se loger
dans des conditions décentes et à un
prix abordable dans le parc locatif
comme dans l'accession à la propriété
vous le savez la crise du logement
véritable bombe sociale comme doquin la
caractérise et avant tout une crise de
l'offre or jamais la France n'a
construit aussi peu de logement et les
prévisions sont toutes catastrophiques
pour produire davantage les organismes
HLM affrontent une triple difficulté la
pensction de 1,3 milliards par an par
une taxe mal nommée réduction de loyer
de solidarité le relèvement de la TVA
mesure que vous avez prise il y a
quelques années et l'augmentation du
taux du livra qui pèse sur leurs
finances alors ma question est simple
alors que nous abordons le débat
budgétaire dans lequel vous mettrez fin
au dispositif Pinel êtes-vous prêt à
affecter ces marges de manœuvre pour un
nouvel effort de construction de
logement à loyer modéré partout en
France très concrètement allez-vous
supprimer cette taxe RLS allez-vous
rétablir la TVA à 5,5 % sur la
production de logements sociaux qui sont
bel et bien un produit de première
nécessité merci je vous remercie la
parole est à Madame Sabrina gresti
roubach secrétaire d'État chargée de la
ville madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
pe notre pays est effectivement
confronté à une crise immobilière de
production liée entre autres à la hausse
soudaine des taux d'intérêt à
l'augmentation des coûts de construction
consécutif vous le savez au conflit en
Ukraine à la crise des permis de
construire dans certains endroits
d'autres territoires comme Marseille par
exemple les mesures prises par le
gouvernement visent à apporter une
réponse à la crise sur tous les segments
de l'offre s'agissant de la production
de logements sociaux l'accord conclu la
semaine dernière pour la période
2024-2026 par le ministre du Logement
avec l'Union sociale pour l'habitat
prévoit la mise en place de 8 milliards
d'euros des prêts de prêts pardon à taux
bonifiés pour la construction de
logements très sociaux plai et de
logements sociaux c'est une économie de
charge de plus de 650 millions pour les
bailleurs sociaux par ailleurs la Caisse
des Dépôts et Consignation va accroître
son enveloppe et je m'en réjouis de prê
participatif pour la pour la ptere
pardon de 250 à 400 millions d'euros de
plus comme vous l'avez souligné nous
allons accompagner la rénovation du parc
social à hauteur à hauteur de 1,2
milliards d'euros pour les trois
prochaines années les fonds propres donc
des bailleurs seront ainsi préservés
pourront alors être réinvestis dans la
production nouvelle enfin nous nous
engageons évidemment à étudier toute
opération qui serait confrontée pardon à
des difficultés de montage pour trouver
des solutions avec vous je vous remercie
je vous remerci madame la ministre
monsieur le député oui merci pour la
réponse mais vous avez pris il y a
quelques années des mesures
injustes que vous considériez justes au
regard de la crise d'aujourd'hui et de
la l'augmentation des donintérêt il
faudrait revenir dessus merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame Caroline
Abad pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma on s'adresse à Monsieur le le garde
des saau samedi les villes de zederot et
ofakim deux petites villes d'Israël ont
été la cible d'une attaque calculé et
ordonné du Hamas 900 civils des hommes
des femmes des enfants ont été tués
blessés la première des humanités est de
regretter ses morts puis la
responsabilité de tous ceux qui ont une
audience et de condamner cette attaque
terroriste sans ambigué
être critique vis-à-vis du gouvernement
d'Israël c'est légitime mon groupe le
rappelle sans cesse malheureusement
certains oubliant leur part d'humanité
et leur responsabilité sont allés
jusqu'à justifier cette attaque
terroriste le conflit
israélo-palestinien a toujours raisonné
très fort dans notre pays tout ambiguïé
dans ces moments-là est irresponsable
qu'est-ce que ces ambiguïtés produisent
le sentiment qu'on pourrait faire
l'apologie du terrorisme en toute
impunité pire encore on a vu des
internautes sur les réseaux sociaux se
féliciter de ces attaques
qu'est-ce que cette apologie du
terrorisme produit des actes toujours
des actes on a vu depuis samedi une
récrudescence des actes motivé par
l'antisémitisme le plus vilain nous
connaissons ici mieux que quiconque la
force des mots monsieur le ministre même
s'il s'agit d'une frange étroit de notre
société qui s'est déchaîné sur les
réseaux sociaux un état de droit ne
serurait laisser impuni cette apologie
du terrorisme je voulais savoir avec le
renforcement des moyens mains que nous
avons permis depuis 2017 à Faros avec
avec le budget historique alloué à votre
ministère et alors que la loi sur le
numérique n'est pas encore votée si nous
avons tout de même les moyens de lutter
contre cette apologie du terrorisme sur
les réseaux sociaux ces citoyens ne
distinguent plus le digne de l'indigne
nous devons leur ramener nous devons les
leur rappeler à minima ce qui est
illégal de dire
publiquement je vous remercie ma cher
collègue la parole est à monsieur Éric
duporetti garde d' saau ministre de la
Justice merci Madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les députés madame la
député abadis qui a frappé Israël samedi
dernier c'est le
terrorisme et dernière ce mot ce cache
un coupable c'est le Hass et l'Union
européenne a dit très clairement que le
Hamas était un groupe terroriste il y a
aucune ambigué sur cette question je
veux ici rappeler au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale que notre pays pays souffre
encore des stigmates de
l'attentat du 13 novembre et que
certains ont préconisé que le Hamas et
les représentants d'Israël se mettent
autour d'une table c'est comme si on
nous avait demandé à nous gouvernement
de la France de nous mettre autour d'une
table avec daesh alors vous avez raison
Madame la Députée il y a des règles et
vous allez souffrir que je vous les
rappelle la démonstration de soutien à
un groupe terroriste l'apologie du
terroriste c'est un délit c'est une
infraction c'est très clair
je veux également vous rappeler que les
auteurs de messages incitant à porter un
jugement favorable sur le Hamas le
Djihad islamique en cours 5 ans
d'emprisonnement je veux encore vous
dire que s'ils diffusent leur discours
de provocation sur les réseaux sociaux
ils en cour non plus 5 ans mais 7 ans
d'emprisonnement dès samedi j'ai demandé
au procureur de la République au
procureurs généraux
en lien avec ces attentats perpétrés en
Israël de poursuivre et 10 enquêtes je
vous l'indique sont actuellement en
cours par ailleurs il y a quelques
minutes j'ai signé une circulaire pour
demander un traitement immédiat un
traitement ferme et naturellement un
traitement systématique de toutes ces
infractions le terrorisme n'a rien à
voir ici son apologie non plus merci je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Stéphanie Galzi
pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé monsieur le
ministre je m'adresse à vous avec la
gravité qui convient à un sujet aussi
lourd en tant que député mais aussi en
tant que femme 200000 c'est le nombre de
femmes qui se sont fait implanter le
dispositif de stérilisation et sûr en
France entre 2002 et 2017 suite à un
véritable emballement commercial autour
de ce produit particulièrement rentable
et dont la mise sur le marché a été
suivi avec négligence plusieurs milliers
d'entre elles ont subi de graves effets
secondaires survenant quelques mois
après l'implantation leur faisant vivre
un véritable calvaire ces effets
secondaires ont bien souvent entraîné
une impossibilité de travailler et donc
une perte de revenus ainsi que leur lot
de difficultés familial personnelle et
social des vies brisées ces femmes ont
bien longtemps été discréditées et se
sont vu déigner le statut de victime
elles se sont même vu affirmer que leur
problème étaient d'ordre psychologique
et
psychosomatique des femmes qui se
sentent humiliées lorsqu'on leur fait
remarquer que ce n'est pas grave si au
final elles sont mutilées puisque de
toute façon ellees souhaitait une
contraception
définitive
déconsidérer lorsque l'indemnisation de
ces femmes dépend des organes de
celles-ci et ne sont ramené qu'à leur
utilité procréative oui monsieur le
ministre dans notre belle République une
femme ménopausée ne reçoit pas la même
considération qu'une femme en âge de
procréé ce sont au final entre 25 et
30000 femmes qui ont dû se résoudre à
recourir à l'explantation
50 d'entre elles se sont décédés en 2018
dans un silence coupable votre solution
et l'étude hble ne correspond pas aux
besoins des attentes des victimes que
vous n'écoutez pas et malgré leurs
courriers successifs alors Monsieur le
Ministre quels sont garantie que vous
apportez qu'une telle négligence ne
puisse se reproduire je vous remercie
merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame an firin
le budau ministre de la de la prévention
et
[Musique]
de merci madame la
présidente des professions de santé
merci merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés madame la
députée Gal
vous m'interrogez sur le médical
dispositif médical et sûr il s'agit d'un
dispositif médical implantable de
stérilisation définitive etréversible
indiqué chez les femmes majeures en âge
de procréé il n'est plus commercialisé
en France depuis le 18 septembre
2017 un comité de suivi des femmes
porteuses du dispositif û a été mis en
place par le ministère de la Santé dès
octobre 2017 pour répondre aux questions
que les femmes peuvent se poser
notamment lorsqu'elles présentent des
symptômes pouvant être en lien avec ce
dispositif dans le cadre de ce comité en
lien avec la NSM la HAS et le collège
national des gynécologues et obstétrit
France et les associations de patientes
un plan d'action a été formulé il vise à
garantir la sécurité des conditions de
retrait du dispositif lorsque cela est
nécessaire et pour assurer une
information complète des femmes
concernées la procédure de retrait du
dispositif doit être ainsi réalisée
conformément au protocole établi par les
gynéco comme le prévoit l'arrêté du 14
décembre 2018 afin favoriser la bonne
application de cette procédure une
nouvelle campagne de communication
auprès de l'ensemble des professionnels
de santé concernés a été mise en œuvre
ce registre la création d'un registre de
suivi des explantations comme vous l'a
dit a été mise en place en avril 2023
afin d'améliorer le suivi des patients
concernés ce registre permet d'une part
de collecter les données individuelles
des femmes relatives aux antécédents
médicaux chirurgicaux aux effets
secondaires au mode modalité
d'explintation et d'autre part le suivi
de l'état de santé des femmes après
explointation du dispositif enfin le
ministère de la santé et de la
prévention assurera le financement d'une
étude concernant les éventuels symptômes
des femmes après ablation de l'implant
contraceptif et sûr piloté par les
Hospices Civils de Lyon cette étude
explorera donc notamment l'hypothèse de
la libération de métaux potentiellement
toxiqu qui pourrait être en lien avec la
symptomatologie présentée par les femmes
il est prévu que l'étude démarre au
premier trimestre 2024 un tel drame ne
doit pas se reproduire indépendemment de
la gestion des suites de ce dossier il
nous faut être irréprochable dans la
gestion de la certificate certificate
merci beau beaup madame la
ministre madame la
députée madame la ministre ces femmes
sont ici aujourd'hui regardez-les dans
les yeux et dites-leur qu'elles sont des
victimes collatérales d'un État qui
refuse de prendre des responsabilités
merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame Sylvie
ferrire pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur ah ça marche pas ça ne marche
ça ne marche si ça merci madame la
Présidente
ma question s'adresse au monsieur à
Monsieur le Ministre de la santé et de
la prévention le mardi 4 octobre c'était
l'opération ville morte à bannière de
bigor sous-préfecture de 7000 habitants
ce sont près de 3000 personnes qui sont
descendues pacifiquement dans la rue
pour défendre l'hôpital public et son
service des urgences en plus d'être
fermé la nuit depuis plus de 2 ans le
service a vu une fermeture complète les
3 les 4 les 5 les 6 et 17 septembre pour
le mois d'octobre ce sera pareil et on
ne sait rien pour novembre des urgences
ont fermé au moins ponctuellement cet
été dans 163 communes de France
plusieurs milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées pour la défense d'un
véritable service public de la santé à
carré à auusson à montfavé parce qu'un
centre hospitalier en milieu rural c'est
vital notre système de soins qui était
l'un des meilleurs du monde est
soigneusement détricoté depuis 30 ans
dans votre projet de loi de finance de
la sécurité sociale 2024 c'est 3,2 %
d'augmentation prévue en matière de
soins de ville et d'hospitalisation
c'est bien inférieur à l'inflation qui
est de 5 % dans notre pays à l'état
actuel les syndicats et les fédérations
hospitalières de France sonne l'alarme
on ne pourra pas répondre aux besoins de
la population le personnel médical le
dit on doit faire le tri parmi nos
patients vous entendez chers collègues
le tri des patients dans la 7e puissance
économ
mondiale alors Monsieur le Ministre ma
question est simple est-ce que vous
assumez clairement de ne pas maintenir
notre système actuel fonctionnel et de
condamner certains Français ou bien vous
mettrez les moyens financiers et humains
à hauteur des besoins pour éviter un tri
tragique je vous remercie madame la
députée la parole est à Madame agè fir
Leo ministre chargé de l'organisation
territoriale et des professions de santé
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
ferrire nier ou minimiser les
difficultés de notre système de santé
serait une erreur oui la crise des
urgences n'est malheureusement pas
nouvelle oui dans certains endroits le
système est sur une ligne de crête et
oui cette crise est en réalité la
manifestation de difficultés plus
profondes de notre système de santé
malgré malgré un été difficile le
système a tenu et ce d'abord grâce à une
plus grande anticipation sous la
coordination des ARS dont je tiens à
saluer le travail en lien avec les ux
locaux grâce aussi à des mesures
d'accompagnement et de soutien y compris
financiers mis en œuvre par le
gouvernement grâce surtout et je tiens à
les saluer à la mobiligation des
professionnels et grâce aux
organisations trouvées localement entre
la ville l'hôpital et les élus des
territoires la la situation n'est pas de
binaire ce n'est pas 100 % fermé ou 100
% ouvert sur 680 services d'urgence 5
ont été fermés cet été une quarantaine
ont fermé ponctuellement c'est important
de le rappeler toutefois nous ne pouvons
nous satisfaire de cette situation elle
ne doit pas être pérenne notre
préoccupation est bien le fonctionnement
de la filière urgence de l'amont à
l'aval on le sait les urgences ne
fonctionnent bien que lorsque le
parcours des patient est fluide en amont
la géralisation des services d'accès aux
soins sur l'ensemble du territoire va
nous permettre de mieux répondre et
mieux orienter les patients en ce sens
nous avons annoncé il y a 10 jours un
ensemble de mesures visant à mieux
valoriser les assistants de régulation
médicale notamment via une prime de 100
€ par mois aux urgences il s'agit aussi
de mieux organiser les flux et d'assurer
la sécurité des soignants en aval la
question de la réouverture de lit
aujourd'hui fermé par manque de
personnel est central pour cela nous
avons annoncé côté de la première
ministre pour plus d'un milliard de
nouvelles mesures visant à mieux
valoriser les gardes le travail de nuit
et de dimanche vous voyez madame la
députée nous essayons d'apporter des
réponses point par point territoire par
territoire hôpital par hôpital merci
beaucoup madame la ministre madame la
députée non non non là il y a pas de
réponse à ma question en fait vous
faites le choix de la de la fermeture et
de la mise en danger de nos concitoyens
et
concitoyennes je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Philippe guillomard pour
le groupe
Renaissance
merci merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le gardessau Ministre de la
Justice il y a 42 ans la France
abolisser la peine de mort tournant
ainsi les pages sanglantes de sa justice
selon la formule de Robert Badinter ce
principe a été introduit dans notre
Constitution en 2007 en son article
66-1 chaque 10 octobre depuis 2003 est
organisé la Journée mondiale contre la
peine de mort soutenue par le Conseil de
l'Europe et l'Union européenne lors
d'une table ronde organisée la semaine
dernière par la commission des affaires
étrangères il a été rappelé que 55 pays
perpétuent encore cette pratique
dans un mépris total des droits humains
et principalement à des fins
d'oppression politique en 2022 c'est une
augmentation de 53 % du nombre
d'exécutions qui a été constaté par le
rapport d'amnestie internationale du
fait de l'Iran en premier lieu qui
utilise cet instrument de terreur pour
étouffer toute contestation du régime
mais aussi du fait de l'Arabie Saoudite
ou de la Chine et si le principe
d'abolition universelle progresse
certains de nos alliés applique encore
cette sentence au sein même de notre
pays des ambigués sur cette question
sont entretenu par certains pourtant
nous le savons une justice qui tue n'est
pas une justice plus efficace notre pays
milite et agit par le biais de sa
diplomatie notamment par la présentation
Bienale d'une résolution à l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies monsieur le
ministre compte tenu des chiffres
évoqués comment la France
envisage-t-elle d'intensifier s efforts
pour promouvoir ce principe d'abolition
universelle et surtout avec quel
levier je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à monsieur Éric
duporetti garde des saau ministre de la
Justice madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
guillmard merci d'abord de
rappeler qu'il n'existe pas de justice
qui tue c'est une formule qui avait été
prononcé notamment ici à l'Assemblée
nationale et bien sûr moi je ne peux pas
comme vous m'interdire de d'avoir une
pensée émue pour Robert Badinter et puis
euh pour vos
prédécesseurs et ça n'était pas un
combat facile ont accepé de d'éradiquer
cette peine d'un autre temps de notre
arsenal législatif oui il y a parfois
quelques ambiguïtés qui su qui sont
cultivé j'ai entendu récemment qu'on
disait que l'échelle des peines était
abaissé parce qu'il y avait plus la
peine de mort il y avait une sorte de
soupçon de regret mais passons elle est
aujourd'hui clairement aboli et ce qui
nous pose problème vous l'avez rappelé
c'est ce qui se passe
ailleurs alors la France soutient
euh devant
l'ONU l'universalisation de de de
l'abolition de la peine de mort bien
sûr lors du 8e congrès mondial célébrant
l'abolition de la peine de mort j'ai
proposé à mon à mon homologue allemand
que il y ait comment dire dirais-je une
une formation européenne pour
l'édification des des plus jeunes sur
cette question et cette formation a été
mise en place pour la première fois par
le Conseil de l'Europe en juin 2023
j'indique qu'à titre personnel chaque
fois que je reçois l'un de mes
homologues
étrangers un pays qui pratique encore la
peine de mort je dis ce que j'ai à dire
sur cette question voilà nous sommes
tous mobilisés pour qu'un jour peut-être
le plus vite possible il n'y ait plus de
peine de mort dans notre
monde je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier serva pour le groupe
lot merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues à chaque
tempête sont l'eau de pénurie d'eau et
de pollution aux bactéries coliformes et
à la boue mais disons-le c'est de l'au à
caka NaBr guadloupe Jodel et cela parce
qu'à chaque tempête le smgag syndicat de
l'eau et l'État s'illustre par leur
impréparation la tempête Philippe nous a
touché le 5 octobre dernier et rien n'y
a changé alure où je vous parle ce sont
plus de 100000 usagers qui n'ont pas
d'eau en Guadeloupe monsieur le ministre
et quelle est la réponse proposée par la
RS de Guadeloupe tenez-vous bien je cite
portez-le ébolliition pendant 5 minutes
et laissezla reposer pendant au moins 1
heure nous sommes bien sur le territoire
de la 7e puissance économique mondiale
d'ailleurs la constitution de ces
réserves d'eau participe à la
prolifération de la dingue qui tue chez
nous déjà 10 morts par cette épidémie
cette année au tris répercussion en
Guadeloupe les élèves sont privés d'un
mois et demi de cours chaque année du
fait des coupures d'eau la facture d'eau
est salée pour la population à bout de
souffle dont le robinet est sec et
souillé ainsi monsieur le ministre je
vous rappelle que la sécurité sanitaire
des populations est sous la
responsabilité de l'État soyons concret
nous demandons 1 un déploiement effectif
cette fois-ci du planè au potable je
salue d'ailleurs le travail de Moon
Guadeloupe qui mis a sensibilisé nous
attendons une distribution massive de
pack d'eau dans des zones touchées par
la pénurie 2 la mise en place du même
dispositif Cayotte par lequel l'État
prend en charge des factures d'eau des
usagers guadoupéens jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 3 comme demandé il y a 1 an le
plafonnement du prix du pack d'eau de
1,5 à 1 €. enfin 4 vous veniez monsieur
le ministre très rapidement en
Guadeloupe pour une dernière fois donner
de l'eau à nos compatriotes guadeloupé
en souffrance je vous remercie merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Philippe Biget ministre
délégué en charge des outr m madame la
présidente madame messieur les députés
monsieur le député Olivier servant vous
m'interroger sur le problème que connaît
la Guadeloupe depuis quelques jours
suite au passage de cette fameuse
tempête Philippe et comme vous
connaissez merveilleusement bien ce
territoire vous savez que ce territoire
est coute humieux de tempête or 80 % de
l'eau qui coule rebinée elle vient d'où
c'est de l'eau de pluie et on lorsqu'il
y a des événements climatiques et bien
il peut y avoir des incidents comme ceux
que vous venez de relater qui sont
justes c'est vrai que il y a de l'eau
qui est impropre à la consommation et
l'État l'Agence régionale de STI en
particulier a pris toutes les
dispositions mais pas simplement la
seule ligne que vous avez cité dans
votre intervention mais un courrier que
je tiens à votre disposition pour
expliquer ce qu'il faut faire dans ces
conditionsl et donc 3 villes 100000
habitants ontt pendant quelques jours
c'est vrais pas d'au mais je vous
rappelle monsieur le député et vous le
savez très bien
que en 2021 l'État a pris toute ses
responsabilités il a fait quoi il a fait
fusionner quatre syndicats pour en créer
un seul deuxièmement il a mis beaucoup
d'argent sur la table il faut le
rappeler à tout le monde 340 millions
d'euros d'investissement que nous
apportons pour les quatre prochaines
années il n'a pas fait que cela l'état
il a apporté précisément 47 millions
d'euros en fonctionnement au fameux
syndicat dont vous parlez donc la
situation voyez que l'État a été présent
en accompagnement des collectivités
territoriales et ces distributions d'eau
évidemment ces soucis de factur je les
comprends mais je crois que le syndicat
qui a été vraiment financé à ce
niveau-là peut participer me semble-t-il
à ceager la facture et je voudrais vous
dire enfin qu'on ne peut vraiment pas
comparer la situation avec Mayot ou à la
demande de la première ministre l'autre
jour sur les qure mois de la fin de
l'année
2023 l'ensemble des maoraaises et Maoris
seront exonérés de facture mais pas que
cela la distribution qui s'applique sur
50000 personnes serait élargie à toute
la population d'ici quelques semaines
donc ne comparez pas les choses mais est
présent il est aujourd'hui il le sera
demain avec une eau de qualité merci
Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas Reay pour le groupe des
Républicains merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre du Travail du meddeef à la CGT
vous avez réussi à coaliser contre vous
tous les partenaires sociaux à l'annonce
de votre projet de ponctionner entre 1
et 3 milliards par an dans les caises de
la agir Carco vous le savez ce régime de
retraite est un succès du paritarisme
auquel les Français et notre groupe sont
profondément attaché l'an dernier
d'ailleurs notre groupe s'était battu
pour annuler le transfert du
recouvrement des cotisations à girir
Carco vers les URSAF que vous aviez
décidé nous avions obtenu satisfaction
avant que cette mesure ne soit
malheureusement annulée par le Conseil
constitutionnel alors oui l'gère Carco
dispose aujourd'hui d'excédents mais ces
excédents c'est le résultat de 75 années
de bonne gestion pendant lesquelles des
efforts ont été demandés au salariés du
privé ces excédents n'appartiennent pas
à l'État ni d'ailleurs au syndicat ni au
patronat ces excédents c'est l'argent
des salariés qui ont cotisé toute leur
vie Raon ces excédents ce sont aussi les
réserves mises de côté par les
gestionnaires du régime dans une logique
prudentielle c'est pourquoi cet argent
ne peut aujourd'hui être utilisé
arbitrairement pour combler les déficits
des autres régimes
monsieur le ministre toucher aux
réserves de laager Carco sans l'accord
des partenaires sociaux ce serait la fin
du
paritarisme cette méthode est d'ailleurs
en contradiction totale avec votre
volonté de restaurer le dialogue social
elle est aussi un très mauvais signal à
quelques jours de la conférence sociale
que vous organisez votre argument selon
lequel cette ponction serait prélevée
pour récupérer les bienfaits de la
réforme des retraites ne tient pas cela
ne s'est pas fait par le passé lors des
précédentes
réformes ces nouvelles recettes restent
la propriété de laag Carco alors
Monsieur le Ministre la question est
simple allez-vous abroger le transfert
du recouvrement allez-vous abandonner ce
projet de ponctionner les caisses de
laag Carco qui fait aujourd'hui
l'unanimité contre lui je vous remercie
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du sopt ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député vous avez dit que la
caisse à gircarco est bien gérée c'est
vrai en 2019 par exemple les partenaires
sociaux presque à l'unanimité ont décidé
de la mise en place d'une décote pour
les assurés qui partaient et qui partent
à la retraite à partir de 62 ans mais
avant 65 ans ça a permis à cette caisse
de générer un certain nombre d'excédents
et aujourd'hui nous estimons que la
trajectoire d'excédent pourrait être
autour de 5,1 milliards d'euros au cours
de l'année actuelle et de l'année qui
vient dans il y a quelques mois avec la
réforme des retraites et lorsque nous
l'avons présenté aux partenaires sociaux
nous avons indiqué que notre objectif é
un retour à l'équilibre général du
système de retraite tout régime confondu
ça n'était pas dissimulé c'était
présenté dans le 3e cèle de concertation
entre la fin du mois de novembre et le
début du mois de décembre lorsque au
début du mois de juillet les partenaires
sociaux ont commencé à examiner leur
projet de nouvelles convention nous leur
avons indiqué qu'à horizon 2026 notre
estimation celle du gouvernement était
que la réforme des retraites produisait
de manière intrinsèque 1illard 200
million d'euros supplémentaires
d'excédent excédent qui n'aurait pas
existé sans la réforme des retraites les
services de laagir Carco nous disent ça
n'est pas 1 milliard 2 mais c'est 1
milliard convenez que nous sommes assez
proches en terme d'estimation tion nous
avons dit aux partenaires sociaux que
nous considérons logique que cet
excédent supplémentaire généré par la
réforme soit consacré à un retour à
l'équilibre général l'accord qui soumit
à leur signature ne tient pas compte de
cet objectif il prévoit de nouvelles
dépenses notamment en matière de
suppression de la décotte ou
d'indexation supérieur à ce qui était
prévu pour 1 milliard d'euros 1 milliard
d'euros de dépenses supplémentair 1
milliard d'euros de dépenses publiqu au
sens communautaire du terme
supplémentaire nous avions proposé aux
partenaires sociaux que cette
participation au retour à l'équilibre
puisse par exemple financer des
disposition de solidarité notamment le
relèvement du minimum de pension qui
aura ainsi profité aux salariés du
secteur privé nous regrettons très
clairement le choix qui a été fait car
les nouvelles dépenses qui sont
contenues dans l'accord soumises à la
signature sont en réalité financé pour
l'essentiel par le rendement de la
réforme alors c'est une réforme qui doit
nous permettre de revenir à l'équilibre
les débats budgétaires qui s'ouvrent
devront aussi nous permettre de
retrouver cet équilibre que ce soit au
travers du PLF ou du PLFSS pour garantir
la crédibilité des finances publiques
j'ajoute si Madame la prés merci non
désolé monsieur le ministre
votre temps est écoulé la séance des
questions au Gouvernement est terminée